-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy-nominated actress,
musician, and comedian
you know from films
such as "Ocean's Eight,"
"Crazy Rich Asians,"
and "The Farewell."
Her new movie, "Quiz Lady,"
is streaming now on Hulu.
Let's take a look.
-And your time starts now.
What is the square root of 196?
-14.
-Ron.
-Correct.
How many hearts
does an octopus have?
-Three.
-Ron.
-Correct.
-What?
-What spice is derived
from Crocus sativus?
-Saffron.
-Feel like an answer hog.
Uh, saffron.
-Correct.
-Carbon dioxide.
-Very good.
-Wellington, New Zealand.
-Correct.
-Saturn.
"Our American Cousin."
The equal sign.
-Harry Potter.
-"The Hobbit."
-Correct.
-Sorry.
[ Dog sneezes ]
Bless you.
-Ron...
-Please welcome back to the show
Awkwafina, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Up-tempo music plays ]
♪♪
Welcome back!
-Hey. Good to be back.
-It's great to have you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I really appreciate anytime
someone flies in from London
and still makes time
for our show.
You did that this morning.
-I did.
-How are you feeling?
-I feel -- I feel good.
I feel -- I feel refreshed,
I guess.
-How was the flight?
-The flight was good.
I slept a little bit.
I had been coming back
from a kind of
a weird London moment,
though, so I just...
-Okay.
-Yeah.
-Happy to be home?
-Happy to be home, yeah.
-Okay, gotcha.
-"Weird London moment" --
that's very cryptic.
-Yeah, I -- I had
a chocolate moment.
-What was a chocolate moment?
-That's what people ask me --
right? -- in London.
So, I was at this lovely hotel
that I stay at
when I go there.
Love them.
And I guess I woke up one night
completely ravenous.
And you know, like, in London,
they love
leaving little chocolates.
They leave little chocolates.
-A nice hotel is like, "We're
gonna leave some chocolate."
-Totally, totally.
And I was just --
I just -
I guess I just hogged
all these chocolates
in the middle of the night.
-Like in a fugue state.
You have no memory of it.
-It was in the dark, I think.
It was -- I was
not cognizant
of what was going on.
When I woke up, there was
chocolate all over the bed.
Not only -- On the walls.
-Yeah.
-On the door handles
in the bathroom, right?
-Yeah.
-So I felt horrified
because it's also, like,
I didn't want them to --
you know, they know.
And so I cleaned up
what I could
and I took the wrappers out,
and then I put them
by each of the chocolate stains.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, so then
nobody had to wonder.
-Yeah, you know what that is.
It's chocolate.
-Housekeeping could be like,
"It's bad,
but it could be worse."
-"I think it's chocolate."
-Yeah, yeah.
-Yes, yes.
-Of course, the best
would be if it, like --
if it was not chocolate,
but then you just still left
the chocolate wrappers.
[ Laughter ]
Like, that might be my move
in the future.
-I don't know if that
would be, like, the best.
You know what I mean?
-I think it's the best.
-Let's agree to disagree.
-We'll agree to disagree
on that one, yeah.
-This is a wonderful movie
with you and Sandra Oh.
You play sisters.
It's very sweet.
It's very funny.
You play the more rigid
of two sisters,
who is sort of obsessed,
as we maybe could guess
from that clip,
with game shows.
Were you someone,
as a kid who watched
a lot of game shows?
-Yeah, I definitely did.
There is something
very comforting
about their kind of regularity.
Every day, it happens,
you know, at a certain time.
I really liked, like,
other ones, like, you know,
"Fear Factor"
and stuff like that.
That's not necessarily
a game show.
-There's an element of game
to it.
It's weird watching that --
Or my parents,
who still watch "Jeopardy!"
every night.
Like, there is something
to watching a game
that is about trivia
and knowledge.
-Yes.
-I remember,
when we were a kid,
how often we'd watch --
I don't know,
maybe it's before your time --
There's a game called
"Press Your Luck,"
which is just the dumbest game.
[ Laughter ]
Like, you don't get better.
The only thing people do is
randomly, like, press a button,
and it just stops somewhere.
And then you're like,
"Well, you pressed it,
and that's your luck."
-Yeah.
-And I just, like --
every day, I would watch it,
and I'd feel like
I could be just
such a better person now.
-Yeah, did you...
[ Laughter ]
Was there, like,
an algorithm to it?
-No. And I think
it was, like, before computers.
-Wow.
-So I think you pressed it,
and a guy behind the screen
would just be like,
"I don't know,
put the light on for this one."
[ Laughter ]
I think it was pretty shady,
what was going on.
-That does sound shady.
-You got to work
with an incredible cast.
We saw a standard clip.
We saw Jason Schwartzman,
we saw Will Ferrell in the clip,
Holland Taylor.
Was this a fun movie to make?
-It was such
a fun movie to make.
It was definitely, like,
a collaborative effort.
When all those actors
kind of signed on,
I couldn't believe that.
Like, they were kind of
like the dream, like, people
that we wanted for those roles,
and we didn't know
that they would be down.
And then they were.
And obviously Will Ferrell is
incredible as a game show host.
-It is really fun to watch.
I mean, not only
on "Celebrity Jeopardy!"
but I bet he played at
like seven other game show hosts
in his time at "SNL,"
so it was very fun to see again.
-Yeah. Very, very fun.
-You also had a costar,
which was a pug.
There was a pug in the movie.
-There was.
-And there's your pug costar.
-Yeah.
-And what's
the pug actor's name?
-Oh, my God. Oh, no.
[ Laughter ]
-I have it
if you don't remember.
This is so embarrassing
because they are here.
They wanted to say hello.
-No, no. Oh, no, they're not.
I wouldn't remember their names.
-Look, I'm not going to pull
some Ellen move,
where the -- "Oh, my God.
Do you know what?"
[ Laughter ]
-Are they gonna...
-Do you know
what Awkwafina just did?
You just waved at Wally.
-Yeah. Wally.
-Can we please stop doing this?
-I'm sorry, I love --
but I love Wally.
-You know Wally from "SNL."
-Yes.
-Do you want me to come up?
Should I come up?
-No.
[ Laughter ]
-Why not?
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'll allow you --
I'll allow you
to walk through once,
pumping your fist
like you're really famous.
Go ahead.
-Alright?
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Whoo!
-Wally's the dude, man.
-Oh, my God.
You know what's happening
right now?
This dog is like, "Oh,
she remembers Wally's name."
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, Wally.
I did multiple scenes
with her,
but Wally...
-"I was her costar."
-...holds her cue cards
once on 'SNL,'
and now she's like..."
Uh, Linguine.
-Linguine was his name
in the movie, yes.
-Oh, in the movie.
-So I don't even know
the name of the dog.
[ Laughter ]
Well, you know what?
Let's come up
with a name for him.
What do you think?
-He has a real name.
I feel -- I just --
I feel like it was, like. Caleb.
-Uh-huh.
I'll go with Caleb.
-Yeah.
Was it -- How many --
Because sometimes in movies,
they have to, like,
rotate in the pugs.
Was it more than one?
-They do.
There was more than one.
-Okay. Gotcha.
Well, I mean, it was --
I think it was a good job
for this specific pug.
He was a bit older.
-Yeah, and because, I think,
as an actor,
obviously you knew
it wasn't going to be long-term.
And so you didn't want
to get too close to them
by, like, learning their name.
[ Laughter ]
-Um, uh, no, no, no.
-I don't care that you don't
know these dog's names.
By the way,
neither do these dogs.
-I forget his middle name.
That's true.
No, but, no, he was
a pleasure to work with.
He did have a stunt double
that was female.
And, like, a lot --
significantly younger.
-That might be worse
than the pay gap
is that one -- the male pug
gets to, like, be the actor.
[ Laughter ]
And then, when there's a stunt,
they're like,
"Get the young-woman pug
for the dangerous stuff."
[ Laughter ]
-It actually -- She wasn't
even doing stunts for him.
She would just -- you know,
she would relieve him
when he needed a break.
-Well, that's very, very sweet.
-It was nice, yeah.
-I also want to ask --
the last time you were here --
and it has been five years,
so thank you for being back --
It's so lovely to see you.
-Thanks for having me.
-We talked about
how your grandmother --
her review
of "Crazy Rich Asians"
was, she did not like your wig.
[ Laughter ]
-And I was like.
"Any other thoughts, Grandma?"
-So, my question is,
has she seen this one?
-I feel like someone
had put it on for her,
and then -- ad she, like,
in totally normal fashion,
just kind of paid attention,
then, like, left.
And then I don't understand it.
But then is also
glued to her iPad
like 24 hours a day,
like watching TVs and movies,
you know?
So it's like,
when it comes to my movies,
I don't know if she's like,
"I don't get it.
I don't like it," you know?
-Gotcha.
-But I think that --
-Did she feel
like there's -- like,
if she described your work,
does she feel like it lacks --
Does she feel like
it's not different enough
from film to film?
Like, what do you think
her criticism is?
-I don't know, I don't know,
I feel like it's just being like
an Asian grandma a little bit.
It's like they're never
really going to tell you,
like, when you kill it,
you know?
-Are they just afraid that,
like, if they praise you,
they'll disappear?
[ Laughter ]
-I think -- I think so.
Something in
the realm of that, yeah.
-Something like that.
Well, I have no problem here,
praising you.
It's so lovely to have you back.
It's just such a joy to see you.
Thank you so much.
-Thank you so much.
-That's Awkwafina, everyone.
"Quiz Ladies"
is streaming now on Hulu.
And that's Wally
with the cue card.
We'll be right back
with Micaela Diamond.